let me get to Adam Vinatieri cuz he just
stepped out of a meeting and now he's
the greatest scorer in the history of
the league why were you getting called
into a meeting we get everything from
last weekend keep moving forward we got
a nice bye week that guys deserved but
we we can't we can't just swish things
under the rug if we need to take stuff
wait what did you do wrong well you know
collectively week at home so you have a
perfect game and there's no such thing
as a perfect game I don't think so but
how did you celebrate on a long
four-hour flight home no really it was a
fun locker room after the game on
obviously being able to break a record
in a win is way way more fun than you
know any of that other stuff I'd trade
all that stuff in for four wins so it
was it was awesome in the locker room
was a great atmosphere guys were having
a good time and and you know just you
know all the players showing a lot of
love and it was a pretty cool moment did
you almost get cut your rookie year I
think yeah absolutely I think as a
kicker you're probably about two bad
games away from the the exit door every
every time you step on the field I think
so I start
thanks coach Parcells said I was week to
week at that point so fortunately for me
I I was good enough for a few weeks to
get some games under my belt and kind of
move in the right direction
yeah I wonder what would happen in you
know today's NFL if you I mean you don't
even get that much of a space if you're
unproven then I don't know if you would
have gotten more time or less time now
if you started out that slow what I
agree I think you know if you're maybe
if you're a draft choice or something
they've got a little more invested in
you and make it a little bit more time
but but it seems like they don't have a
whole lot of patience for for missed
kicks this at this day and age and you
know it's it's one of those things
sometimes it takes a little while to get
your
confidence or get the growing pains out
or whatever whatever it is so you find
your your groove I guess so yeah I think
back when I started I think probably mid
70s was your was your field goal
percentage nowadays they expect you
about eighty five percent right out the
gate you coming back next year you know
I haven't put I haven't even put a lot
of thought into it to be honest with you
I think when the season ends I'll sit
there and re-evaluating and if I'm I'm
an asset and not a liability to the team
if I can keep going and and feel like I
can put a good product on the field
I'd love to come back for another year
you know there's nothing like being in
an NFL locker room it's just it's an
amazing feeling and you know it's it's
one of those things our team's trending
in the right direction I want to be a
part of that that's for sure if I could
show just one kick to sum up your career
which kick would it be ooh I think the
one that I'm the most proud of is
probably the one in the divisional
playoff game against Oakland in the snow
bowl
I think that one was probably the the
most difficult one that I had to face
and fortunately for me and our team it
went through but there's been there's
been a lot of pretty cool moments out
there you know a lot of guys mentioned
this last week they somebody showed the
Herschel Walker thing and thought that
was pretty cool I know it was my rookie
but maybe badly to ever play so this is
on a kickoff yeah on a kickoff personal
break to seeing him in he's running down
the sideline and honestly I don't think
I had an angle I just good boy give me
10 seconds of speed that day and tackle
and a lot of my teammates who probably
weren't even born when that happened
don't expect me to be able to do that at
my age now but ya know I think that was
probably one of those special moments as
well hey congrats Adam and hopefully
you're back next year if that's what you
want to do and your family want you to
do it and it's been a great run thank
you yeah thank you Adam military for
more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]